but there's also sound pridefulness  thankful  how did you find our life so beneath you  you've always had a wolf over your head  food in your bed  do you not think that came at Great  Sacrifice from your father and I  oh do you think we are beliefs  if I'm meant to live out the rest of my  days with you and Daddy on this farm and  so be it but I'm only young once  I'll go to this audition and I don't get  picked then I'll come home and I'll  never speak of it again I swear  but I have to know that I tried or I'm  gonna regret it for the rest of my life  please completely you have no idea what  I'm gloves  I've seen the things you've done in  private  and you believe no one is watching  you'll see others won't notice  you can't keep your true self beautiful